oui tu aurais pas au togo tôt à cherves
nous avons ramené les gens dans les
abris ou dans leur maison à peine arrivé
dans les abris l'artillerie russe a
pilonné l'endroit exact où il se trouve
et une demi-heure une heure avant
et ensuite ils ont frappé les bus qui
nous servent à évacuer les civils juste
avant nous en avions 50 il ne nous en
reste que 21
la vérité c'est que nous ne savons pas
combien de gens sont morts ou bien
blessé dans notre ville
selon nos estimations il y aurait plus
de 1000 victimes et plusieurs centaines
d'entre elles seraient mortes
nous ne pouvons même pas ramasser les
corps étendus dans les rues de la ville
parce que l'armée russe bombarde
continuellement
banking cher